just a few months ago anti-gun Democrats
in Virginia thought that easily ramped
through a new ban on so-called assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines now
after all in November they won control
of both houses of the state legislature
first time in 20 years and governor
Ralph Northam was supporting this bill
of course with the phony argument that
rolling back the gun rights of
law-abiding Virginians would make all
Virginians safer this issue generates
great emotion but the facts are the
facts
gun violence takes the lives of more
than 1,000 Virginians every year three
people every day at that rate everyone
on the floor of this chamber would be
gone by March
I love the dramatic pan of the chamber
by c-span now remember this is the
brilliant logic of the same guy who
argued that infanticide is basically a
human right this was all his attempt
keeping keeping the strain and thought
train of thought there to keep all you
gun owners comfortable but Northam
wasn't ready for the pushback was he the
opposition made sure that their voices
were gonna be heard and boy were they
heard you know the deplorable is the
bitter clingers don't target the
law-abiding citizens in this country
you're a citizen if you're born here
you're allowed to protect yourself
we don't want gun control we're not
going to comply with your gun control
you would have a better chance of laying
in a creek and kissing a copperhead then
you would get into firearms from
Virginia's well well the liberal gun
grab went down in flames yesterday with
the help of four moderates in North
impart e as if you went out and legally
purchased a weapon or legally purchased
a particular part just simply by owning
that you could become a class 6 felony
or a class 1 misdemeanor it's not fair
it's not due process and
that was what really bothered me the
most and it's important to note that
this grassroots uprising was successful
despite the millions that have been
pumped into the Commonwealth from out of
Staters like Democrat presidential
candidate Michael Bloomberg through his
group every town for gun safety he
funneled 2.5 million into Virginia last
year to elect anti second amendment
Democrats every town outspent the
National Rifle Association which is
based in Virginia by a factor of 8 to 1
Bloomberg even made a last-minute visit
to the state to make one final push for
the gun ban for the first time in more
than 25 years
Virginia Democrats took control of both
chambers of the legislature and I'm
happy that they won but I'm even happier
about what they've done it's only been a
month since they took office and already
you've taken action to end our epidemic
of gun violence by the way that's
Bloomberg sounding pumped up this is how
some locals graded him
now since 2014 Bloomberg has spent 75
million dollars attacking the NRA and
your gun rights and he's had his sights
set on Virginia for years he's thrown
ten million dollars at Democrats in the
state since 2011 but it turns out
there's still a lot of Jeffersonian
spirit left in Virginia their second
Amendment rights aren't for sale
he can take his money and he can keep it
in New York Virginia doesn't want his
money
he's already tried in New York Virginia
and we're done we don't like it at all
all right that's gonna happen across the
country I sure hope so
but Bloomberg and the rest of the
anti-gun forces in America won't let
this defeat stop them no way governor
Northam is already promising that the
gun ban is going to be reintroduced next
year but what happened in Virginia
yesterday shows that when we the people
argue the facts and we stand united for
a noble cause we can overcome the
corrupting influence of money and
leftist ideology but imagine that
Bloomberg ever got real power on a
national level
he'd learned the lesson of Virginia he'd
move a lot more swiftly against the
second Amendment rights of all Americans
before the resistance could actually
mobilize and he'd sell it all as gun
safety measures which translated means
you have less power and the government
more but a lot of those Big Gulp
drinking Americans he has such little
respect for you know the ones who drive
pickup trucks and actually mow their own
lawns they're onto his big money tricks
a Bloomberg nomination is guaranteed to
do at least two things one motivate the
Republican base and to drive up the
price of Smith & Wesson stock and that's
the angle